[MUSIC
] [MUSIC]
[MUSIC]
Welcome to the tgs 2022 Patton Online Program In
this program, we will bring you information on the latest titles of Gakucon
.
We will deliver the latest information on Monster Hunter Rise's Break Free Title Update 2nd Version 12 First of all, please
watch this latest promotional video
[Applause]
i am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]  ]
[music]
me too
yeah yeah yeah
[music]
The second
version of the 6 Western title update has been decided to be distributed on Thursday, September 29th.
I'm going to do
it, so please enjoy it until the end.
I'll hunt him down. He
usually shows leeway with his aloof movements,
but you
can decide to take Met out seriously. With
his body covered in flames and his violent movements, he turns the surrounding area
into a sea of ​​small villages, and
then revives from Monster Hunter Frontier.
A subspecies of the thorny brown dragon Espinus will
appear.It is even more aggressive than the normal Espinus.
It is said that there is
[Music]
The emergence of interaction that overcomes Yuriatsu's bald squid has been confirmed.
I'm going
to set it up. Please challenge the end of the powerful ancient dragon statue. The
Espinus subspecies who always wakes up will be arrested at
master rank 10 or higher, and the
monster overcoming owner soil will be arrested at positive rank 110 or higher
.
In addition to weapons and
armor, please look forward to new skills.
The level limit for the
Kaito-
class quests has been raised to 120,
and you can enjoy bargaining with monsters with a more tense atmosphere.
You
can use them to expand your weapon's monster slots and
add new enhancement items
.
Almost all weapons up to version 12 will be available
as layered weapons.
Challenge hunting with your favorite combination
[Music]
me
We will continue to add new paid downloadable content
.
We have just introduced the
equipment other than the
layered weapons.
Episode 8
is scheduled to be released on SNS and the official website,
so please wait for information updates
[Music]
Monster Hunter Rise's Break
Version will be distributed on Thursday, September 29th
.
Version 13 will be released in late November.
Updates are planned, and we plan to
continue updating in
2023 Please look
forward to Monster Hunter Rise's
breaking news
[music]
tee
Next,
we'll bring you the latest information on the Resident Evil series.
Hello
, this is Kanda, a producer of Resident Evil Village.Resident Evil Village
released in May 2021
Set in a village full of jerk and madness, this work depicts the death of the main character,
Ethan Winters, and
has sold over 6.5 million copies worldwide.
Thank you for making it
such a big hit. Winters expansion, which includes 3 contents that allow you to enjoy the village even more,
and Resident Evil Village gold edition, which is a set with the main story,
will finally be released next month
.
thanks
add dlc first con  Tents allows you to enjoy the main story of
the Third Person Mall Village from a third-person perspective, which has been requested by many
fans.You can see a lot of e3's movements that you couldn't see from the first-person perspective,
and
you can also feel the fear unique to the third-person perspective.
Combat is a play pit that Chilean fans will be more familiar with than the original Gosaku Tadano In
addition to the Gengaku prize that you can enjoy in early to 8 re 3, you can also use
actions such as guarding and kicking back villages
.
Next up is Shinsei - Shadows of the Nose,
which can also be played from a third-person perspective.
In
this world, a single
hit can kill you.
Stop and be the first to defeat the ninth victory book
Please experience this tension that can make the difference between life and death
What content has evolved The
Mercenaries
Additional Orders An
additional stage has been added to The Mercenaries where you can enjoy high-tempo
gameplay Playable characters will participate and more
Massive play Volume game
New European and American edition
Domi and Risk and Heisenberg Afterwards,
sexual additional characters will finish the
action feed that stands out even in the series
.
Village gold edition is
scheduled to be released on October 28. As a
limited benefit, you will receive
Nose's costume street wolf outfit that can be used in the additional scenario Shadows of Rose
. Please make a reservation.
But
you will be able to
play Resident Evil Village on your mac
in 2022 and bye
apple sir  i With the recent
support, I was able to
demonstrate the powerfulness
of the
delicate graphics.
We would like more people
to enjoy the Resident Evil series,
so we have decided to
distribute the Nintendo Switch cloud version.
Appeared in a cloud version that can be
played while connected to the Internet Game fans who have never had a village play environment before
can now play
Release date October 28, 2022 It's
good to go
The additional content
winters x version introduced this time
Scheduled to be delivered on December 2nd A trial version that
allows you to check the operation of the Proud version is
also being delivered
The cloud version on the Nintendo Switch is
also scheduled to be delivered Resident Evil Cebu Resident Evil r 5 Resident Evil re 3
Resident Evil 7 cloud version is
out  A new appearance as a free version The
Resident Evil Village we've introduced so far
is at the
Tokyo Game Show 2022 Kakone booth, and we're exhibiting the
PlayStation vr No. 2
playable You can experience the ultimate immersion, so please come
Next, I have received a message
from this title scheduled to be released next year
.
Thank you very much
for
your time
today.We are developing Resident Evil for PlayStation
5 and other latest generation consoles,
but we are also doing well on current generation
consoles.
I would like to take this opportunity to let you
know that
this work will be compatible with PlayStation 4
Oe.  We've
decided to bring
you the Ohazar Showcase, and I hope that we'll be able to provide you with plenty of the latest information and appeal of
this work.
This is the latest information on the action title
exo primal Hello Ekud primal I'm
director Hiya Ohana
First of all, please watch this video
Ah ah ah
[music]
What should I do with Space
Tan
?
music]
careers ibo on good bullet day man I
'm not forced to fill out
there is no big garbage
ss 5 towns line pyon central ibs decided
big course for
source
It's Rawlings, go-
ha--
none It's
really salty and salty, but you've already seen
it Oh
eco the lovely now I
can't put straws in It's not my
favorite
camp,
it's just dyed and repaired
[Music]
Unique
perder bar
Ector Muse huawei asc
to  do robbery meeting
bach noh
mic recording psoc
mtber you already brave
sep temoure house adviser
voodoo i
think down you chin
spray for challenge
integration
good deal
[music]
parent are
reer hondukchu
big story
board yeah yeah
voodoo face ocd way yeah yeah yeah
this time there are 4 penkey battles and melody 4s and
enemies are good Moody blues beauty health
finished leaves with road
5 c clip rubber single
9 morning long
How was it?
Rift primal is
an online-only massive team-based
action game produced by Capcom.I would like to introduce the
latest information contained in the video you just saw
in a little more
detail.The stage of this work is set in the year 2040.
and people are attacked A
shared disaster occurs  The player
decides to become Egu and Hoop pilots who will compete against Ai Ryusha in a world where the player is in 2043.
In 2043,
while introducing the surroundings of Kita Tower, the carrier that the main characters ride is caught in a giant ball x and
crash-landed on the island.  The story
begins to move in a big way from
i Joining ai A big game that is repeated by the speed,
dinosaurs that appear beyond time and space, and
battles between exa fighters
Players are caught up in the big game, and
Ikuta who organizes Iwayayama for survival.  You will be challenged with missions A
story that approaches the world's mysteries will
be gradually unraveled by playing Ranked Survival.From
here, we will introduce the characters deeply involved in the story
.
It is called by a nickname.It is
the alter ego of the player,
and its appearance can be customized through
character creation.Let
's take a look at the members of
the unit
Hammerheads, to which the main character belongs.  is called Chief
Next is Alder, an engineer with a prosthetic right arm
And another Ezo suit pilot
Majesty
Lastly, l is a support android 3d placed in the fighter unit
These four people meet one body  I
'd like to introduce you to the key characters in the story.
One is Magnum, the exosuit who teaches us how to survive in certain situations and how to survive in a certain game
.
And in this video, a new f-zo
suit appeared. Murasame
has a warrior-like appearance with a weapon in the form of Kiri Ichimonji. The
road is a tank.
While guarding,
use a
counter to eliminate the seat.When you activate the counter, you will be in a rakshasa state
and your fighting ability will be temporarily strengthened.
Wave
Doll is a support
Blocks enemy vision Optics
Jammer is effective against Ezo suits on the enemy team as well as shared
16 waters enemies and immobilizes enemies within range of 2
Supports the team with tricks that interfere with
enemies.In addition, a new blade has appeared with a lift that allows you to wear an exosuit
costume.Throws an
ionizing shuriken and can temporarily increase the hit enemy
to create a moon.
Of course, we shouldn't forget about
them.The newly introduced dinosaur in this video is the
Well 4 Saurus, which has a scarf-like appearance.
Carnotaurus has a large body, but it is
a fast-moving dinosaur. It
tortures the player with powerful lunges and thrusts
.
Tyrannosaurus is
the answer with overwhelming attack power.
There are other suit-rigged dinosaurs out there
, so please wait for future announcements
.
There is a hangar in the carrier
where you can customize suit skis, weapons,
skin decals, charms,
etc. You can customize your suit by changing its appearance
Em auto wear stamps can be set
Communication wheel
Increases the durability of the suit
, increases the reload speed of the weapon, and more.  Various customizations are possible, such as modules that
change the performance of active skills for each suit
. There are various ways to obtain
items and modules that can be used for customization, such as
playing Boasting Goodness
and obtaining experience points to raise your player level and suit
level.  However, the
more you play the game, the more you get.For example, you can have
a suit that looks like this, or your little
sister.We have prepared a wide variety of items and modules that can be used for customization, so you can
create a Ubud suit that you like.
This work will be released in 2023. We are working hard
to prepare for its release.
Rockman EXE series
that is still loved by many fans The numbering tree works are Nintendo Switch
PlayStation 4
Mega Man EXE Advanced Collection on Steam
2023 Released in 2023
High image quality that can be switched to soft drawing as a feature in the advanced collection
Bankruptcy of filters and
gallery mode Over 1000 illustrations in total
and 188 stations in the game  Includes a
music player that allows you to enjoy
bgm
[Music] The
sound of
Panmegu Mei Abyu is waiting for a lot of days.  Person in charge
Various reactions will be returned depending on the play situation and the operation
And we have received a comment from the director of this work, that
master of the
battle operation set
.
EXE is
back
Rockman EXE Advanced
Collection It's
been about 17 years counting from EXE 6. I'm very happy
to be able to share EXE information with you again
.
Look
, the motivation of the development staff
is rising By the way,
there is something that everyone is really worried about
[Music] Please be relieved
about the communication function
We are still connected.
I
'm currently working on communication functions such as trading.  Please wait for the next report.
Separated into vol 1
and volume 2 are also scheduled to be distributed separately. Please check
the official website and Rockman series official Twitter for product details and future follow-up news
[Music] The
last title I will introduce today
Hello everyone
, this is Nakayama, director of
Street Fighter 6. Thank you for the many responses to Street Fighter 6, which was announced in June.
Today we will bring you the latest information.  First of all
, please watch the video.
No
tee. No. Regular par 5
ana.
4 minutes
.
a
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah [music] got up to haa follicle mouse rar # ebe me yes 2
voodoo spell view position
[music]
[applause]
goo
yeah yeah yeah . rar dee dee voodoo oh oh oh oh
oh
oh ana yeah yeah yeah
[music]
e7
dare to do
[music]
[applause]
ah ah ah ah ah
wh
Fighter 6 has
3 main
modes: World
Tour Fighting Ground Battle
Hanyu.  ]
Farmland and
Farming Let's start with
Dhalsim, a master of Western paintings.Even in
this work with many students studying abroad, he is a character who uses a long reach and fire skills to
attack tricky attacks.
I'm Edmond Honda, a hot-blooded wrestler.I
fight with my weapons of dynamic strength and repair
power.Metro City Smart Chanko Nabe is a
restaurant where you can enjoy
Sumo Chaya, but it seems that Fumi got you excited.
Also
appearing in
amazon.wow he who is a guide
also has a new costume prepared from the
air  Attack area reloading
has been added, and
techniques using the Dranka-chan doll are also
available.
[Applause]
ah ah ah
[music]
me
Variety of visitors,
Liu Bei Gyeong who jumps up and throws a sharp kick, and
New Day Sasa have also learned and expanded the range of fighting
Street Fighter 6
So, there are a lot of new characters and familiar characters from the series
, as well as beef
asebi stew. Please look forward to it.
It's battle content.
You can fight by combining the rules that determine victory and defeat with the banks that appear in tizen. You can fight
by selecting a bomb gimmick that bounces when you hit the attack on the rule that knocks down the opponent 5 times first
.
Unique.  It will be a battle with different rules, so
I think you'll be able to experience something different than
usual.There are various other things in the store ground
.
Please take a look at the video that these people participated in the
live commentary.
It's hard, but I'm going to raise my strength The
heart state drive is beautiful
I'm glad that the inner blade is falling down here
me
Woman smoked Asaka's why damn it I'm going to decide
Hair
Let me show you the limit of bloodline
Ah ah ah
mc Should I fight
with all
my soul  I'm looking forward to
future battles.
Let's meet again.
Hirai, who is well-known for being a shogun, participated in Kosuke. There is no doubt
that the match will be lively with an easy-to-understand and polite commentary
.
We are working hard to ensure that a wide variety of people can participate in Street Fighter 6,
so please look forward to future announcements
.
The main character who becomes an alter ego will meet various awards and
become stronger through street competitions
What kind of teacher will you learn from?
You can enjoy your own story in this world
.  Music]
t 4
[Music]
Not only height and body type, but also muscle mass and
character
can
be meticulously detailed.  You can demonstrate your individuality Not
only your appearance,
but also your character
's performance will change by performing a funeral.  It is
possible to
immediately battle in various locations
, and high yin and yang and galleries will also gather
.
You can learn skills and buster actions in the game.Of
course, you can use them on the site,
but those skills will be reliable when you move around the city or when you explore.
The
world tour, such as obtaining and customizing, is a completely new mode where you can
enter the world of
Street Fighter and experience the world of Street
Fighter.  It
will
be a place where you can enjoy various games and communication while connecting.
You can easily enjoy the battle have much as soon as you sit in the battle
cabinet.It feels like you
are in an
arcade.It
is possible to participate in tournaments without fear of battle.
Have
fun customizing your avatar
You can play nostalgic titles on the game
consoles in the arcade.  We
are
developing a space called Battle Hub that you will want to visit every day
. Please look forward to it.
Please
en un des frl 3 just stick it on
nails er I've got it all a 4
door open na
melania
[music]
no
Sorry to keep you waiting
.  You can participate within the
period.  We
will continue
to release the latest information on Street Fighter 6 on the official website and twitter.In
addition, we will broadcast a special program Street Fighter 6 special program from 24:00 on Friday, the 16th of the month Japan time tomorrow.
I'll give you the information, so don't miss it
Thank you for your continued support of Sukjong, who was on the street
. Did you get the latest
information?  Please
take a look [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] Next is an
introduction to the sale of
popular titles at affordable prices.  is on sale for a limited time
It's underway
Monster Hunter Rise's break is on
sale for the first time
Monster Hunter Life is also on
sale, so don't miss this opportunity Check out if
there are any titles you missed the chance to play, such as Resident Evil Village and Capcom Fighting Collection
[Music]
Tomorrow, Friday, September 16,
24:00 Japan time, we will broadcast a special program called
Street Fighter 6 Special
Program
.
Please watch the introduction video of the 4 Resident Evil series that has been decided to be distributed on the Nintendo Switch cloud version
[Applause]
[Music]
Ahhhhh
That's all for today's information.
Please look forward to
it Thank you for watching until the end
Yay
[music]